nous avons un ambassadeur de choix sur
le plateau que j'aime beaucoup qui est
moussier tombola heure d'affluence
heures qui a décidé de se mettre au
service du téléthon et sa des verts
bravo il fait des vidéos qu'on fait des
cartons 160 millions de le veut il y
avait un titre alors je n'arrive pas à
dire ce mot donc je vais vous laisser
dire le nom nous à ce titre c'est ton
lequel le premier le premier oui alors
tout le monde l'appelle corde à sauter
mais s'appelle logobitombo voilà le banc
d'essai pour ça que je possède le club
tango
il a lancé il a lancé un défi pour le
téléthon un hashtag téléthon sauter plus
haut exactement en quoi ça consiste plus
beau des questions sauter plus haut
bondir plus hautes et bondi plus
exactement quels principes le principe
est très simple c'est que le hashtag
téléthon challenge a été lancée et les
internautes
et comme les influenceurs comme les
sportifs peuvent reprendre l'un des caps
chalenge donc notamment moi le bon dit
plus haut et le bon dit plus haut comme
je suis un mec qui a créé corde à sauter
et donc ça me correspondait un petit peu
j'ai décidé de prendre trois de mes
chansons 3 refrain de les coller et d'en
faire un challenge
on l'a des images regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non bigot d'acheter des accessoires bien
sûr à 100 le drame dont je fais des
démonstrations en tant que non pas en
tant que boxeur boxeur de haut niveau
c'est bien fini
[Applaudissements]
ok
pour les moqueurs bine bine j'avais
envie de voir sauter vous donnez une
corde
j'aimerais qu'on ait quelqu'un qui a du
robot c'est magali bertaud sera allégé
non plus elle est ultra longue
c'est un peu
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien la version peu écolière
maintenant bon bah on va tomber de
charybde en scylla rebondi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
[Applaudissements]
alors là la vraie je vais les garder les
godasses ça j'arrive à la branche rdc
c'est bien on y brasse allez on avance
on avance allait le téléthon ça s'est
fait casser 6 4 et 5 c'est important on
n'a pas vu les images du parrain de
cette année c'est monsieur m pokora
c'est avec une grande joie et une
immense fierté que j'ai accepté d'être
le parrain du téléthon cette année je
connais le combat des familles des
parents des enfants de leurs proches je
sais la passion et l'énergie des
chercheurs
je sais le dévouement la générosité des
bénévoles alors grosse pensée pour vous
également
ce que je sais aussi c'est les espoirs
et maintenant les victoires cette année
en va être fort et tous ensemble partout
en france grâce à votre mobilisation
alors vous pouvez compter sur moi on se
retrouve les 4 et 5 décembre pour le
prochain téléthon
et n'oubliez pas 36 37 étaient lettons
point fr 36.5 est important et conserver
l'avancé considérable et les progrès qui
ont été faits grâce au téléthon donc
c'est plus maintenant ça fait quoi cette
pâte que 25 ans 30 ans c'est très très
important alors qu'est ce qui vous a
décidé à bout cela a beau lancer dans
l'aventuré shamekhi de base aime
énormément déjà des les défis et le
téléthon en particulier que je suis
depuis très très longtemps
moi pour moi donner donner un coup de
pouce aux gens qui en ont besoin ça et
c'est naturel chez moi
et donc j'ai accepté sans réfléchir donc
si vous voulez faire le défi oui oui j
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est que bien
entendu cette année y'a plein de
manifestations qu'ils ne peuvent pas
avoir lieu
mais j'ai fait un tour des régions
partout c'est en ligne en drive donc on
peut il ya plein de gens qui agissent et
on peut donner
et n'oublions pas que c'est déductible
des impôts pour tous les gens qui
donnent ça c'est très important mais 50%
c'est ça ne va pas jusqu'à 66 % passant
de 6% oui mais toujours appelé aussi
comme vous l'avez dit qu'il ya beaucoup
de progrès qui ont été faits notamment
avec les dons notamment dans le
traitement et l'accompagnement des
personnes qui sont par exemple atteintes
de maladies et attentes il un milliard
d'euros depuis la création du téléthon
un milliard pour l'art leur jeu contre
les maladies rares donc c'est que ça
sert beaucoup sur les maladies rares il
ya en france on est à trois millions de
personnes qui sont atteintes de maladies
rares dont 50% sont des
au moins 18 ans on parle souvent d'une
somme à vis de la mucoviscidose il ya un
an sont en avant et tout l'argent
évidemment les réparties dans tous les
domaines cette année c'est véritablement
important de se mobiliser par rapport à
la crise sanitaire ils ont déjà anticipé
d'avoir une perte entre 30 et 40% sur la
collecte de fonds donc même un euro
symbolique quoi que ce soit 36 37 il
faut vraiment tout le monde soit
mobilisé mais ainsi on compte évidemment
sur vous